[Música]
quería empezar contando esta historia
con esta imagen
esto es fondo miedo es ponte pulsada y
es una postal de 1906 actualmente ahí es
donde vivimos y trabajamos lo curioso de
esta imagen es que al mismo tiempo que
se tomaba esta imagen tenemos esta otra
que esta es una foto familiar por parte
de la familia de mi padre el niño
pequeño que está a la izquierda
su abuelo fernando fernando en el menor
de 10 hermanos y como muchas historias
en las familias de galicia tuvo que
emigrar a américa
siete de los diez hermanos marcharon y
no volvieron él en un principio viajó a
cuba y estuvo ahí unos años y cuando
tienen tomada la decisión de volver a
mondoñedo se encuentra con una vidente
la vidente le dice que no iba a volver
que él no iba a volver a mondoñedo él no
le cree y bueno al pasar unos unas
semanas unos días se entera que su madre
había fallecido él quería volver a
mondoñedo para encontrarse con su madre
y antes pues esta situación decide
decide no volver y seguir su camino
hacia buenos aires lo que la vidente no
pudo adivinar ni decirle es que él no
volvería pero nosotros si volveríamos
volverían mis padres y volveríamos
nosotros en 2004 venimos a mondoñedo
mi hermana y yo y nuestros tres gatos
también nosotros venimos a mondoñedo con
14 15 años a la misma edad que fernando
se marchó de aquí
es una época de bueno de adaptaciones y
de maduración y sobre todo de de tomar
decisiones personales términos
secundarios y tome la decisión bueno de
estudiar el bachiller de artes en burela
estando ahí un profesor siempre no se
insistía en que estudie hacemos bellas
artes pero no me terminaba de convencer
y en una de sus clases sin querer nos
pregunta qué es el diseño y el diseño no
hacía la respuesta de bruno munari que
es el padre del diseño gráfico y el
diseño es solucionar problemas a partir
de ese momento me quedé fascinada y es a
lo que a lo que me dedico ya lo que me
dedico hoy en día soy diseñadora gráfica
y junto con mi hermana que diseñadora de
moda nos unimos si seguimos trabajando
en un taller y en un oficio familiar de
la conocer y grafía
entre nosotras nos unimos y creamos lo
que serían sinergias igual que el
oxígeno y el hidrógeno forman el agua
pues nosotras creemos que juntando
nuestras nuestras ideas y nuestros
potenciales podemos crear cosas mucho
mejores no solo sumar sino también
multiplicar
en
[Música]
como concept y como conclusión final
creemos en ponte pulsada
aquí donde estamos hoy en día que sigue
siendo prácticamente el mismo sitio
creemos que en realidad somos el
resultado de todas las decisiones que
tomamos pero sobre todo de las
decisiones que tomamos en los momentos
más difíciles en los momentos en los que
tenemos que ser resilientes
y quién sabe si algún día en una charla
te decks algún sobrino algún nieto algún
familiar mío esté hablando de las
decisiones que hoy tome o qué futuro
tomar en un futuro
[Aplausos]